many of us know the struggle of trying
to balance school or work with our
favorite hobbies whether it's sports or
gaming it takes a special type of person
to be able to properly manage one's time
in order to be successful with each and
every thing that one does sacrifices
need to be made in order to pursue what
we love but almost always there comes a
time where you must choose
one passion over another
that following day they asked me to join
their team
and that was like a
huge life decision because i would have
to leave school
and
in my mind i had already made up that i
was gonna try to do this because this is
like what i worked towards for years but
after being told what he can and cannot
do his entire life
there is one man who managed to prove
each and every one of his doubters
wrong
meet rowan magnet brain cruthers the
inspiring australian world champion
swimmer who has successfully taken his
competitive spirit from the pool onto
the server
from westlake
oh my god
now rowan might appear to be your
average everyday cracked egamer and the
truth is that he is that
but he's also so much more you see on
top of juggling the rigorous schedule of
being an elite international swimmer and
head clicking enthusiast rowan has done
so all while living with cerebral palsy
i remember having tests done by doctors
that said that i may never be able to
walk again so how exactly did a
phenomenal paralympic champion become
entangled in the at times weird world of
esports what sort of obstacles has he
had to overcome throughout his life both
offline and in matchmaking and how is he
using his inspiring journey to change
the perception of disabilities in gaming
you find it difficult to drive because
you said you have your lower bottom
yeah i use hand controls because i can't
coordinate my legs properly
right so i have a
i have a lever that sits below my um
indicator and i push it to break and i
pat it down to accelerate this guy can
change his binds
that is insane
okay guys so before we get into rowan's
incredible story please do me a favor
and like the video subscribe to the
channel and if you are so inclined turn
on notifications also be sure to check
out our weekly streams over at twitch.tv
slash the score esports we hang out play
games shoot the [ __ ] with random guests
and occasionally host watch parties
alright so before he was terrorizing
players as sova in matchmaking and
became a two-time paralympic gold
medalist where did this 24 year old
australian icon's journey begin well
rowan was born in sydney back in october
of 1997 but before he'd even breathed
his first breath
he had to overcome an extraordinary
amount of adversity you see during the
time that rowan's mother was pregnant
she contracted septicemia a
life-threatening blood infection and in
order to protect both his and his
mother's lives doctors were forced to
bring rowan into the world early i was
born at 25 weeks prematurity which is
about 15 weeks early and i had a lot of
associated um dramatic stuff that
happened around the time that i was born
one of which was resulting in being
diagnosed with cerebral palsy which is a
kind of brain damage that impairs fine
motor skills and coordination
at the time um my disability was
recognized as being quite severe i
remember having tests done by doctors
that said that i may never be able to
walk again
by doctors that said that i was within
the bottom half a percent of the entire
population for
intellectual ability
and all this kind of stuff all these
people that were putting labels on me
saying that i'm never going to be able
to do this that or the other never going
to be independent despite the severity
of their son's diagnosis rowan's parents
were determined to give their son the
best life possible so from his early
days they did everything in their power
to help him including moving the family
to brisbane to be closer to his father's
workplace but on top of that rowan's
mother began investing more and more
time into conductive education a type of
therapy that is commonly used to help
children with cerebral palsy become more
independent and it was crucial for
rowan's cognitive and motor development
one of my core memories is um eating a
little tub of just like yogurt
and it would take me maybe an hour an
hour and a half to eat this thing that
would take me 20 seconds now because my
mum would sit there and force me to pick
up the spoon and put it in my mouth and
eat it myself the moment she gave up and
said all right i'll spoon feed you that
was over for my brain and it would say
okay i don't need to do this anymore by
the age of seven rowan had made
incredible progress and it was then that
he began a new type of physical therapy
one that would become one of his life's
greatest loves although in the beginning
like a lot of kids
he kind of hated it when i started
swimming i was red hot garbage at it
i actually have school report cards from
my first couple years of school let's
say that i failed swimming and couldn't
do anything right at all just straight
f's in all of it i really really didn't
enjoy swimming at all but i understood
that i had to do it as a part of my
therapy because swimming is a really
amazing kind of sport where you use all
of the muscles in your body to stay
afloat and to move but it was around
this time in rowan's life that he
discovered another activity that he
genuinely loved right off the cuff
gaming initially he played n64 titles
like mario kart with his sister but
eventually started playing early
iterations of counter-strike with his
father and uncle on pc for rowan gaming
offered a world where in spite of his
disability he could still compete and
have fun with his friends and family but
it also became a haven for him to escape
the problems he was facing at school a
lot of issues going through school as
well
not just with bullying by other kids
that didn't understand a disability and
just saw a clumsy kid but it was also
issues with the system and schools not
willing to
bend to allow me to be able to access
all of my classrooms safely
get to and from a lot of that kind of
stuff in spite of the struggles he was
facing in the classroom rowan continued
to juggle school playing video games and
physiotherapy but his motivations began
to change in the summer of 2008 when he
first discovered the paralympic games
and subsequently his biggest role model
peter leake an australian swimmer who
shared the same condition as rowan and
that was a really eye-opening moment for
me because for a long time i always saw
the paralympics as being something that
only people that use wheelchairs or
amputees could compete in not for people
with cerebral palsy or forms of brain
damage or anything else so once i saw
that that was an avenue and an
opportunity that i could really be
successful in i started loving swimming
funnily enough i said mum and dad you
know this is what i really really want
to do i want to be successful i want to
go and chase that dream after watching
his hero strike gold in beijing rowan
began training more and more with hopes
of following in his hero's footsteps and
five years later all his hard work came
to fruition when he joined the
australian swim team but there was
one tiny little problem
you see back in 2012 when rowan was in
the midst of grinding his way to the top
of australian swimming
he
like many of us
became extremely addicted to cs go
magnet's brain was the alias he played
under and while it came from an inside
joke about his head attracting the ball
in water polo it also matched his knack
for finding skulls in the server in time
rowan became so good at the game that he
took his talents from matchmaking to
australia's burgeoning competitive scene
people dead one monsters
now in the beginning rowan proved that
competing in high level cs wouldn't come
at the cost of achieving his goals in
the pool as he managed to place first at
the australian open swimming
championships and claim a gold medal at
the 2014 commonwealth games but after
being reclassified into a more difficult
field of competitors ahead of the 2016
rio paralympics he failed to land a spot
at the podium and for rowan
that
simply wasn't good enough being the
competitor that he is rowan set his
sights on redemption at the 2020 tokyo
paralympics but he knew that in order to
achieve the success he dreamed of he
needed to make some sacrifices and i had
to quit from counter-strike
competitively because
it was starting to clash swimming and i
reached a point where i understood i had
the capacity to improve a lot more and
to reach a professional level but i
couldn't chase that because if i did my
swimming would suffer and i would no
longer make australian teams because
honestly the amount of effort and the
amount of dedication that it takes to be
a pro esports player is absolutely on
par of any other professional sport it
takes so much dedication so much time
and effort and energy much to esports
credit i think it's amazing that it
takes that much hard work because
it's the best of the best that we're
competing with each other but right as
rowan's training was ramping up for the
paralympics
kovid hit australian shores in early
2020 putting his dreams of a world
championship on hold indefinitely so
what do you do when there's nowhere to
go and you can't hang out with your
friends
well like many of us rowan's answer was
to play video games
thankfully
the timing couldn't have been better
because it was right around then that
riot games decided to drop the valorant
beta and thanks to its shared
similarities with counter-strike it
didn't take long for rowan to uh dive in
head first
one enemy remaining last player
oh my god wow
magnets just flipping it right
[Applause]
what is oh
for rowan valorent wasn't just a social
outlet or a time waster it was a way to
feed the competitive hunger that had
been left from being unable to swim so
in no time he formed a team with some
fellow shooter-obsessed aussies under
the name pants down
we have cover and elbow trying to hold
that position in fact he flashes through
the wall
actually warbanging him in the end and
gets that pick how many more could he
find oh my god they're all lighting up
and cover fights four out of nowhere
overlord left in the one on five will be
taken out and it's a flawless round
there four pants down rowan and his
compatriots competed in some smaller
events within the oce region and they
consistently placed among the top teams
but with valrant's esports scene ramping
up and first strike events getting
announced worldwide rowan recognized
that he had a chance to shine on a
larger competitive stage
although pants down was able to
successfully make their way through the
first qualifier once the unforgiving
swiss format stage got underway they
unfortunately stumbled out of contention
but as disappointed as rowan may have
been with how things played out the
truth is that it wasn't actually a
terrible result for him competing in
valorant had been fun for rowan but
swimming remained his greatest passion
and with covered restrictions beginning
to loosen up across australia he was
finally able to resume his preparation
for the rescheduled tokyo paralympics in
2021 and although he nearly missed out
on qualifying for his event when rowan
turned up to the tokyo games he popped
the hell off not only did he secure his
first ever paralympic gold medal in the
50-meter freestyle but he added a
further gold and silver to his hall
before heading home but for him his
triumph in tokyo was about way more than
just winning medals just imagining the
impact that i could have had by winning
my medal and speaking in my interviews
on many other young kids in australia
and around the world whether or not they
have a disability to then chase their
passions
that's something that's brought me so
much joy so much happiness after getting
home from tokyo rowan's celebrations
were muted by his obligation to
quarantine for two weeks but that didn't
stop his fans from showing their
appreciation by sending him food and
even hooking him up with a pc to help
him kill time of course rowan was
playing valorent but instead of
competing he focused his attention more
on content creation with the intent of
becoming an advocate for inclusivity and
accessibility within esports you see
while the gaming industry has made
significant strides over the past couple
of decades when it comes to inclusivity
disabled gamers often still find
themselves on the outside of the fun due
to the challenges that they face whether
that's in the form of bullying and
discrimination or even just a lack of
accessibility features rowan stands as
the latest and arguably highest profile
addition to a small but growing group of
individuals who are not only trying to
raise awareness about the challenges the
disabled gamers face but are also
proving that they can compete at a high
level and actually have a good time
i'm just really trying to push in the
content space and trying to stream
valorent and trying to get that exposure
out there for
the importance of not bullying other
people and how regardless of whether you
have a disability or not you can still
have fun at the game you can still be
good at the game and you can still make
a lot of friends i think it's really
important to have that kind of exposure
out there it goes without saying that
the past couple of years have been
extraordinary for rowan on top of
bringing home three medals from tokyo he
was awarded the medal of the order of
australia in recognition of his
remarkable achievements but it really is
just an incredible honor to be
recognized by my own country and my own
nation for doing something that is
as incredible as winning a gold medal
since then rowan has shown no signs of
slowing down he's continued to rack up
medals in the pool and still finds time
to bring his winning positive attitude
to twitch
that's champo honey
let's chamber dead
hitting him with a happy face
without question rowan's journey has
been nothing short of incredible in the
span of 24 years he went from being told
he'd never be able to walk to becoming a
world championship caliber athlete all
it took was the support of his loved
ones and his own determination not to be
defined by anybody other than himself as
one of esports's most inspiring figures
rowan is now using his platform to
partner with some of the biggest brands
and organizations in the space
to spread his message the gaming is
and always will be
for everyone and i think that's this
really really incredible opportunity for
so many so many people with disability
young and old to be able to
just make friends through gaming
compete within the esports
world
and just have a lot of fun
oh my god i'm so sick
you are
i'm assuming on pc
there was no n64 version of counter
strike yeah yeah yeah
i know it's like super straightforward
but from a grammatical stamp standpoint
it makes it sound like we're saying